- The people that are
really trying to get me
are the ones that are
auditing, and I use,
like auditing "The Five".
So they're actually, it's like
they're not taking
the course, you know.
They're showing up in the
back hoping that the professor
uses the wrong pronoun.
That's what I notice
that it's more like.
So you know, like I would
assume that at least once a week
there is somebody deliberately
trying to destroy my career.
But I can't let that stop me.
I've talked about this
in previous books.
We all have to share the risk.
And I have to always, I'm not
blowing smoke up your ass,
but I have to say that you
helped destroy cancel culture
by monetizing the act
of being canceled.
If you get canceled and
there's another way out,
you will always rise above.
(mysterious music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the number one late night
show host in all of television,
as well as the author
of the brand new book,
"The King of Late
Night", Greg Gutfeld.
Gregory, how are ya?
- I am fantastic.
- Is it Gregory?
Is it Gregford?
What is it really?
- I like Big G.
Because I've got
a dog named Gus,
and he's Little G and I'm Big G.
- Is Gus with you today?
- Yeah, Gus is with me.
Would you like to see him?
- I'd like to see Gus because
everything you're doing
on Instagram is Gus-related.
Give the people what they
want, then we'll talk
about politics and media
and all that nonsense.
- Look at the little boy.
- [Dave] Oh, look at Gus.
Look at Gussy Gus Gus.
- He's like, he's
looking for food.
He's looking at my manager,
who's a big pushover, Eric.
(lips making kissing noises)
All right.
- Gus is welcome to make
as many guest appearances.
You are the king of late
night and the walk-on.
The guest appearance
is a big thing.
Before we do anything
here, Gutfeld,
I want to throw back to me.
- You know, you were
on our first show.
What did you say?
So I have to call you out,
because I doubted you.
What did you say
on the first show?
- Well first off,
before I tell you that,
I just want to say
on the off chance
that I say anything
offensive here
during the Gutfeld
explanation point program,
I just want to say
I'm doing today's show
as a Black lesbian.
(crowd laughing)
That's what I'm
identifying as today.
But on the first show,
the first "Gutfeld" show,
I was sitting in this chair
and I said you would be
the number one king in
late night within one year.
And Greg.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you.
I said no, it's not possible.
- Gutfeld, you did it
even faster than I said.
I've gotta give you credit, man.
- You were so certain
that it was happening,
I believe that you willed
it to happen, right?
It's kind of like, you
know, when Scott Adams talks
about affirmations.
- It was the secret.
You said it's going to happen.
I think I might have
been a little reluctant,
and you said, "No,
no, no, no, no.
There's no way it can't happen."
Basically you looked at the
environment and you were right,
that there was this gap, and
they were all feeding, aw.
Now he's back.
And they were feeding off.
- Is that Gus or your wife?
What was that?
Oh, that's Gus,
that's Gus, okay.
- (laughs) He felt bad.
Now there is the
dog that I know.
But you were right,
you were right.
You hit it.
I was gonna say it was
gonna take like a year,
but it was six months.
It was not even six months.
All right, now he's gonna go.
You got five seconds
of Gus there.
- We got extra Gus.
Well you know, the thing is,
man, it was obvious to me
because you'd obviously been
doing it at the weekly level.
I'd done it a million times.
It was and is fun.
And you, people always
ask me about you.
I get probably asked about you,
in terms of what
he's like off camera,
more than anyone else,
because you know,
you're sort of like right
between corporate press
and like online media, so
everyone wants to know.
To me, it's like they
turn on the camera.
You are exactly the same.
You're having fun.
It's kind of messy.
And how many people
even work for you?
You know, the other
shows have what,
50, 60, 80 people
working for them.
You've got like two guys.
- I mean, if you factor
in crew, 12 people, 12.
And I mean, like you can look
at something like Colbert.
I think it's like a
couple of hundred.
Let's just say a thousand.
- A thousand, no, it's
definitely a thousand people.
- So it's roughly 12.
Of course we do use the
studios that are used
for other people,
so that's, you know,
but we have a small staff.
And generally, you're right.
I mean it's like
there's no reason for me
to differentiate between
what I am in the green room
or at home, and what
I am on the show.
I'm 58, and I know I
don't look it, thank you.
- No, you look 56, honestly.
- Yeah, I look a smidge over 56.
But it's like what's the
point of working that hard?
I got here this way.
I mean, I don't even know, I
wouldn't know what else to be.
So that means if I
find that a story sucks
in the middle of doing
it, I will say it sucks.
If I lose my train of thought,
I will say I lose
my train of thought.
If I say a joke and
nobody laughs at it,
I'll be like, why
aren't you laughing?
I'm not gonna sit there
and be talk show host guy,
because I'm not.
I mean, I keep
saying this to people
who say, "You're a comedian."
No, I was running editorial
meetings for most of my career.
I think right now, I guess
now I have as much on TV
as I did in publishing.
Publishing, I quit in 2004,
so that was like 14 years.
And now it's like probably
13 years, 14 years.
- How did you do that jump?
Actually I don't think I know.
How did you do the
jump from publishing?
You were doing men's
fitness, right?
Was it men's fitness?
- No, men's health.
How dare you?
- Men's health, sorry.
How'd you make that jump?
- That's like comparing
Fox News to Newsmax.
Huh, how dare you?
- Sorry, sorry.
- Actually, you know,
the irony of this,
and it's like if
you look backwards
and try to reverse engineer
a career, it's impossible.
But it had to do with me
being editor-in-chief of Maxim
in London, and I was
interviewed for something
called "The Black
Table" by A.J. Daulerio,
who then got famous because
of the gawker lawsuit.
- Oh right, right,
right, right, right.
- And it was a
really fun interview.
And Matt Labash saw it, and
Matt Labash had been asked
to be an original blogger
on The Huffington Post,
and I think The Weekly
Standard wouldn't let him do it
because Bill
Crystal's an asshole.
- (laughs) They can
fact check that.
The fact checkers can fact
check that, it's true.
- It's very easy to check.
But so Labash said,
"Dude, you should do it,
you should do it."
And I go, "I can probably do
it because Maxim doesn't care."
And so they must have sent
that "Black Table" interview,
and then I get hooked up.
That's how I met Breitbart.
So there was like the first day
that The Huffington
Post launched,
and I was like seven, eight
hours ahead or whatever,
and I wrote, I treated
The Huffington Post
like it was an online bulletin
that's done by your aunt.
So it would be like
a lost and found,
there's a weird cat in
my yard, stuff like that.
So the first one was a
recipe for lemon squares.
And so when the thing launched,
they had something
maybe by John Cusack
or some celebrity
about politics,
and then you would get to
me, and it would be like,
you know, here's a great
recipe for lemon squares.
And then an hour later, I
would post something like,
I found this in my yard.
It looks like a G-string.
Does this belong to, and
I would mention the names
of the people on
the Huffington Post.
So it was almost
like, you know what,
it was like a bulletin
board at a dormitory.
So it was all these lost and
found things, complaints,
get togethers later, like
Byron York's gonna have
a get together at his place.
It was to create a
fantasy of something
that really didn't exist.
- Did you bring that to Fox?
Are you the guy
that brought that?
Because that is one of the
things, you do it all the time.
You make fun of everybody
that's on the network.
They make fun of you.
And you can see you guys
genuinely like each other,
where on CNN, when it would
be Lemon handing it to Cuomo,
it was like you two
despise each other.
- And what did they say?
I love you, I love you
man, I love you man.
And it was so clear they
would sue each other
into oblivion given the chance.
But it's the secret sauce of,
I think, success or chemistry.
The secret sauce to chemistry
is the ability to tease people.
And I've been doing
this all my life.
I get accused of
being mean because,
people who don't
understand the relationship
between me and Kilmeade.
I love Kilmeade.
- [Dave] Yeah, it's great.
- Because Kilmeade
is the perfect foil.
Like he's just always
like, "What are you doing?"
And I would make fun of him.
But it's because I love the
fact that he's impervious.
So we get along.
A lot of people go that
Greg is really mean
to Brian Kilmeade, he's
really mean to Kat,
and it's like Kat writes the
introductions that I use.
But the thing is if you see
me not teasing somebody,
it's because they're
not worth it.
Or they're so thin-skinned,
it's not even,
like I don't want to get
a call later saying like,
"So and so appreciates
that you'd just leave
her or him out of it."
I won't say who
these people are,
but there was one female
who's no longer at Fox
who had her own show, who
I even apologized to her.
Her name's not, doesn't rhyme
with Meretta Bran Lustern,
but it could be.
- I think I got it.
I think I got it.
- Yeah, but I even
apologized to her
and she called me an awful human
being and blah, blah, blah.
But I realize there's
some people who have been,
I don't know, in this
cloistered world so long
that they're not used
to somebody saying
a joke about them.
And I think the only thing
I said that was mean to her,
bad about her, it was a
softball interview with Trump.
That was it.
And it was just a silly joke,
and she, man, she was pissed.
So I learned that,
okay, steer clear
of the humorless people.
I don't want them around me,
but the people that I really
like, I will tease them
till the end of
time, because to me,
that's the only way I
can express affection.
I'm not good at the
other ways of doing it.
It's like when I first, "The
Five" kicked off quickly
because I made fun of Dana.
Dana was in a world where
nobody made fun of her,
and we were seated together
for height reasons.
Because you know, when
you're planning a show,
it's all about the lighting,
and you can't have me
seated next to, I
don't know, Jesse,
because he's tall and I'm short.
So she's like this,
I'm like this.
I'm actually more like this.
And so we were seated together,
and it was like being next
to the serious homeroom girl,
except that you could
tell that she was fun.
There was something
going on in there,
and she was never
allowed to go, pssh.
So I just started, and I don't
even know what I was doing.
I was making fun of her, but
in a kid brother sort of way.
And that was the immediate thing
that kind of got picked up.
And meanwhile, you know,
there's Beckel, who's hilarious,
ripping on everybody.
But anybody who wasn't
amenable to teasing never lasts
because they can't handle
it, and they think like,
oh my God, you made a
joke about me on camera.
I need to be outraged.
It's like, no you don't, the
moment you laugh and come back,
everybody loves
it, they love it.
- And to your credit, I'll say
something nice about you man.
We've done it on your show
where you'll make a gay joke
about me and then I make
a short joke about you,
and it's like we're not angry.
Like these people
that are just looking
for everybody to be pissed.
But do you think, is that in a
weird way, more than anything
the secret to you becoming
the king of late night?
Like it seems so weird to me.
Like Johnny Carson was
the king of late night,
and now it's Greg Gutfeld.
It's just so insane.
- You're gay?
- After 10:00 on weekends.
- Yeah, I mean I know you're
married to a guy named Dave.
- He's gay, he's gay.
- I just thought
this was all a sham.
I thought this was all just
a way to get identity points,
DEI, ESG and everything.
- Pretty clever,
my straight friend.
It's a miracle you
did it on your own.
- It was a long game.
Yeah, I think so.
I think that there's a bit of
coziness with the celebrities.
When you bring a celebrity
on, they're like in this cage,
and I don't like to do that.
Like here, we're gonna
have this person come out,
he's got a movie out.
Don't ask him about the divorce.
Don't ask him about his
kid being picked up.
You have to talk
about the movie.
I can't do that.
Like Jay Leno was, think
about Jay Leno with,
who was the British actor
from "Love Actually"?
- Oh, with that famous one.
- Hugh Grant.
- Hugh Grant, thank you, yeah.
I think around '92, yeah.
- Yeah, and he said
something like,
it's funny how you know
the exact date, Dave.
- Yeah, I'm a student
of late night.
Oh no, maybe we
might have been '95.
Google Hugh Grant on
"The Tonight Show".
I think it was '95.
- Do you remember the
name of the hooker?
She had a really cool name.
She had a cool name
like Daisy or something.
She was beautiful, a
beautiful Black girl.
- We'll get it.
I don't have 12 staff members,
but I've got somebody with a
computer in this room right now
and I'm gonna find out
what year was Hugh Grant
on "The Tonight
Show" with Jay Leno?
'95, I did it!
And what was the hooker's name?
What was the hooker's name?
We'll get it.
- Daisy, Dotty?
- Doreen, Dora?
- Doreen?
- Doris?
- Doreen, Doris?
- Delilah.
Divine Brown.
- Ah, Divine.
- Do you see what happens, Greg?
We're at the age.
You're a little older than
me, but we're at the age
where you basically just
have to point to people
to ask them things, what
happened that day, you know?
They weren't even alive.
- But I think that is the kind
of, it is the whole point.
The show is no different
than having people over
in your living room.
And so the people at home
get to know everybody better
because they get to
know the real you.
If I'm making fun of you
and you're making fun of me,
they learn more about
us than they would
if you had shown up
on any other show.
Now, you could argue, and
I'm sure someone would make
the argument, Greg, if you
had Hollywood celebrities
on your show, your
ratings would be higher.
I don't buy that at all
because we're beating them.
And Carson and Letterman,
they were different.
I mean, Carson, which
is the next step,
he had big stars and they
would just rip each other.
Some of them would be drunk.
- Oh, the incredible
Dean Martin and Sinatra.
Oh my God.
- Burt Reynolds, do you
remember Burt Reynolds?
- Oh yeah, he'd go on
with Dom, and yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, no, it was great.
And so I think I
feel like the people
that I have on my show are
stars in their own right.
- Do you think it's
kind of weird or bizarre
that you're on a
cable news network
where everyone is watching
you, waiting to destroy you
at any given moment?
You do a little bit more of a
straight thing on "The Five",
but you know, you're
yourself, but the show is
a little more
straight or narrow.
- It's weird because
what the irony is,
more dangerous on "Gutfeld",
they leave me alone,
but the people that are
really trying to get me
are the ones that are
auditing "The Five".
So it's like they're not
taking the course, you know.
They're showing up
in the back hoping
that the professor
uses the wrong pronoun.
That's what I notice
that it's more like.
So you know, I would assume
that at least once a week
there is somebody deliberately
trying to destroy my career,
but I can't let that stop me.
I have to, I've talked about
this in previous books.
We all have to share the risk.
And I have to always, I'm not
blowing smoke up your ass,
but I have to say that you
helped destroy cancel culture
by monetizing the act
of being canceled.
If you get canceled and
there's another way out,
you will always rise above.
The perfect example is Jason
Aldean getting targeted,
his song goes to number one.
There are a lot of other things.
And then there's the
reverse, that if you try
to be the opposite of cancel
culture, that is, woke,
that will have an effect,
like the Bud Light thing
where that is actually
people, not social media,
but people going,
"Do you know what?
I don't like that they're
trying to sell me something
that's so fake."
And by the way, the
consumer had to be educated
on why Bud Light did that.
Bud Light was trying to
supply their brownie points
for ESG or DEI.
- For ESG, yeah, yeah.
It had nothing to do
with the consumer.
And so it meant let's
make fun of the consumer.
And so the consumer's going,
"Why is this happening?"
They get educated, and
they're going like,
"Well, screw them.
There's a shit load of
beer out there I can drink.
It doesn't have
to be Bud Light."
- What do you make?
- So you can have,
like, go ahead.
- No, no, no.
No, you go, you're the guest.
Continue.
- I already forgot
what I was gonna say.
- You were really gonna bring
home the Bud Light point.
I think you were gonna
connect it to Target.
- I know, here's the
thing, here's the thing.
I don't believe that
boycotts are good.
However, I think that
when you see that somebody
is trying to pull
a fast one on you,
that's worthy enough to call
it out and to avoid them.
And then when you see somebody
who's being unfairly targeted,
that is when you share the risk,
and that is when
you go like, okay,
I'm gonna go buy
Greg Gutfeld's book
because they accused him of
being a bigot or a racist,
because I know he isn't.
I want to have the
Jason Aldean effect,
where it's like, oh,
so you said a song
that has no Black people in it,
that has no lynching
narratives, is racist.
Okay, you're trying to
destroy this person?
I'm gonna make this
song number one.
- What's your policy on when
you're watching the clips
of the lunatics of "The
View", or the crazy people
at the televised mental
institution of MSNBC,
when you're prepping your show,
because I have no doubt
you're going through
the same thing
I'm going through.
On one hand, I want these
people to be ignored
and disappear and whatever.
On the other hand, they are
literally writing our shows
for us, and I do think
they have to be exposed.
But I always have this
little internal struggle
with how much attention.
- I know, I know.
- So what do we do
with that, Greg?
- Do you know what it is?
- We monetize it, I guess.
- It's like you have to
take a tolerance break.
Do you know, when like people
smoke, let's say, the herb,
and you realize your tolerance
level's gotten so high,
you need to take a tolerance
break from gotcha videos.
When I look at "The View" clips,
if there is a punchline
for me exiting it,
then I've gotta use it.
Because everybody
loves those clips,
and if you have a good zinger,
boom, you put that in there
and that's fun.
A lot of people do it
themselves on Twitter.
You know, they'll
tweet something and go,
I can't believe
this or whatever.
But if I have that clip
of, you know, Joy Reid.
Like I got bored with Joy Reid
because everything
was the same thing,
and I realized maybe
I'm helping her.
But if I got a really good
comment coming out of that
that I know is a surefire laugh,
then you have the
evidence there.
You don't have to set up
the joke, the joke is there.
It's like it's free
money, as they say.
- Yeah.
Since you're on the corporate
side of this, so to speak,
you work at a corporation,
it's a big corporation,
one of my things
lately has been like
when I'm making fun of Joy Reid,
to me it's like I don't
know if at this point
she's a willful idiot
or if she's genuinely
the racist lunatic
I think she is.
But I keep thinking,
isn't this really about
not just the
producers above her,
so like the EP in charge of her,
but the exec in
charge of that guy,
and then really all the way up.
Can you just talk a little bit
about corporate
structure in cable news,
because I think people
are wondering about that.
Like they know every
day they put her on air
or they put any of these people.
- Like how can they do that?
How can they do that?
But then I'm sure over
in their territory,
they were saying the
same thing about Tucker
or about me or Jesse.
It's weird.
MSNBC's weird
because, excuse me,
I'm having three fluids,
and I put up four.
MSNBC didn't start this way.
I mean, MSNBC had Tucker,
and Tucker's side kick,
I think, was Rachel
Maddow, if I remember.
- [Dave] Is that right?
- Yeah, and I think
they had Charles Grodin.
- Oh, they did have
Charles Grodin.
They had Phil Donahue.
I mean, he was a lefty,
but not bananas, yeah.
- Yeah, so there was-
- They had Drudge.
They had Drudge at one point.
So it was kind of like they
were finding their bearings,
and then this was the
beginning of the siloing,
where I'm going to this side,
you're going to this side,
and they saw a
monetary possibility
in creating a silo
specifically for that.
And then what happens is, and
it's a destructive incentive,
and you have to be
careful with it,
that you will be rewarded.
The more certain you are, not
the more outrageous you are,
but the more certain you
are about your position.
I have never been one to be,
I don't like the
idea of certitude,
and I think you're the same way.
It's like it feels
good to be wrong.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- It's like a great feeling.
Like I've had this come to
Russell Brand moment with him,
where it's like, you
know, I was a dick to him
and he was a dick to me.
I was a dick to Glenn
Greenwald, he was a dick to me.
But it's like it feels
really good to realize,
I screwed up, they
might have screwed up,
but I might have
screwed up more.
But it's like if you are just
that person every single day
that comes in and goes, this
is the most outrageous story,
I've never been more
outraged in my life.
It is the worst.
I don't even know.
There was one person
talking about me that said,
I had to step away from
the TV when I saw it.
Remember the line on Twitter
that you'd always hear.
I'm literally shaking.
- I'm literally shaking.
- I'm literally
shaking as I tweet this
because this man
is so disgusting.
So it's that sort of
thing in this incentivized
world of outrage that
just creates more clicks
and makes more money,
and I think what happens
is you might not even notice it.
It's interesting when you
see people who get fired
and they end up somewhere
else and they change.
So maybe Chris Cuomo,
is he now in NewsNation?
He's probably not the
Chris Cuomo at CNN, right?
- I know, he suddenly
sounded a lot more like us,
not that anyone's
watching, but yeah.
- Exactly, exactly, and I
think you're gonna see that
with Don Lemon, Stelter, the
people that put on the costume,
then take it off.
- Are you saying Stelter
was wearing a fat suit?
Is that what you're
telling me there?
- Boy, could you imagine if
that, I mean, my goodness.
Could you imagine if
he wore a fat suit?
- Yeah, the fancy people.
- How big that would be.
- Yeah, that's an
expensive fat suit.
- Yeah, Brian Stelter.
- Let me ask you some
serious hardcore questions.
Are you ready?
- Yeah.
- You live in New
York, you sick freak,
you live in New York City.
Blue, blue, blue, blue, blue.
You were there during COVID.
I remember you were
texting me pictures
as all hell was breaking
loose literally outside
of your apartment.
What is going on with
New York City now,
and do you feel like it's
ever gonna turn around?
We're going hardcore
now for a few minutes.
- I think there's a
sense of giving in,
which is the same as giving up.
I notice on Mondays and
Fridays there's not a lot
of people in the city,
and it has nothing to do
with weather or holidays.
The people that can
afford to leave, leave.
So really, New York for a
lot of people is three days.
And I come in, I go
to the, I have a cabin
about an hour and a half away.
And I come in Monday,
and it's amazingly fast.
And it's like there's
nobody on the road,
there's tons of parking.
And then on Friday it's like,
oh, I'm gonna hit
a lot of traffic
when I leave work on Friday.
You don't, because
everybody left on Thursday.
Nobody's there.
So I think what's happened
is instead of trying
to improve the city,
the people just reduce
their presence in the city.
And so you still have, it's
strange how the sadness
and the depression of a
city has moved to midtown.
It's not like the
lower east side.
- [Dave] Right, right.
- It's actually
where people work,
because there's
fewer people there.
And so when you have
less foot traffic,
you have more bad things.
And I know that everybody says,
oh, the broken windows
theory has been debunked.
No, not really.
I mean, when they
keep arresting people
that do little things
and you find out
they're wanted for big
things, maybe it's there.
But I think that you have
graffiti, you have theft,
and it just gets worse.
And then pretty soon you
have, I have this weird,
all I see on the streets when
I'm driving up on the city
from like SoHo up, I see,
if I pick an age group,
say the 35 year old
human being, women,
they're all in Lululemon
going to their yoga
or Pilates classes.
They're just walking.
The men, strung out.
Now, I'm eliminating
tourists and UPS and FedEx.
It's strange how the men
have become thoroughly
almost emasculated by drugs.
They're kind of just, they're
sad, they're depressing,
but they're almost not harmful,
except for the ones that
will beat the shit out of you
or push you in front
of a subway train.
But it's like then
you have women.
- Except for those.
- Except for those,
a small exception.
But you see women, and
they're going to work
because it's almost like
what's this strung-out
fentanyl-laced guy
gonna do to me?
And the worst, they
take up the bus stops.
They sleep in there,
it's all there.
So you have all these
little middle-aged women
who are going to
do their maid jobs
having to stand, you
know, on the side.
But it's almost all drug-induced
men, drug-addled men,
and women getting to
their exercise classes.
That, to me, describes
Sixth Avenue.
- What do you make of that?
You're a Jordan Peterson
guy and you pay attention
to all of this stuff.
What do you make about what's
happening to young men,
as a guy that was
writing a men's magazine
and editing a men's
magazine and all that?
- I would say just off
the top of my head,
men are more inclined
to take risks,
which is why they're
more into drug abuse.
Women, when they run into
problems, tend to look for help,
whether it's self help
books or exercise.
So in this weird time, you see
a lot more women exercising
and a lot more men
abusing substances.
I think that might be the thing.
And because there's
so many men that are,
they're not the same
kind of criminal.
They're not like, in
the crack epidemic,
violent or dangerous because
they're too strung-out.
There used to be this
belief that their drugs
were being spiked with fentanyl.
And it turns out
they're looking for it.
That totally blew my mind
when I first heard that,
because I'm going,
there's no way,
because I've known
three people personally
that are dead from fentanyl,
and they weren't
taking it on purpose.
- [Dave] Oh wow.
- But when you talk to those
in the know with drugs,
they're like, no.
They're like fentanyl
is a desired.
It's like the drug dealers
wouldn't put it in there
if they weren't making money.
So there is a desire for
that next level high,
and I think you're seeing
that on the streets.
I think that there is
a hole for meaning,
and I think that people are
filling it in the weirdest ways.
And women are on their
own, and men have kind of
abdicated their role in society.
I don't know if it has something
to do with culture or what,
but I kind of sense that,
that we've retreated
into our own camps.
- So when you see
that in the city,
I mean, you know I
freaking left LA.
I used to live in New York City,
so now I'm here in the
free state of Florida
where it is just
booming and flourishing.
It's hot, but it's okay.
It's the price to
pay for freedom.
Like I see all
the goodness here.
Do you see any way out
for the city itself,
the people you're
talking about, all that?
- I would, I mean, I
think that it's like,
oh God, it's like
a marriage, okay?
So it's like you have
a husband and a wife,
and they're different.
And they have to each bring
their different tool set
to the marriage, and
you're missing the dad.
So what the woman brings is
the compassion and the caring
and all that stuff,
but without the dad,
you have people aren't in
jail, prisons are closing,
you can walk in anywhere
and take anything you want.
I feel like there needs to be-
- Do you pay for things
at the Duane Reade,
or do you just walk?
- Not anymore, not anymore.
- You just take
whatever you want.
- Yeah, I take whatever I want.
This laptop, I
just walked out of.
And these are not even mine.
I took these from an
elderly woman at a bus stop,
just ripped them off her head.
And then I told her to
buy my book, and she did.
- And she did, wow.
- She ordered it on her laptop
before I took her laptop.
- You're covering all the bases.
- The analogy is imperfect,
but what I'm trying to
say is there needs to be
some sort of yin and
yang relationship
between the carrot
and the stick.
And Republicans were
always the stick,
and Democrats have a
hard time being the stick
because they're supposed
to be the carrot.
And so the moment you
have a Democrat like,
I don't know, Mayor Adams
talking about justice
or prison time, his
whole side turns on him.
You need a Republican.
So it's like you need to have
the carrot and the stick,
the husband and the wife.
Or the husband and the husband,
in your case, Dave and Dave.
Which one of you is the stick
and which one of
you is the carrot?
Have you ever
thought about that?
- Greg, can we take
this off camera?
- Yes, yeah, we'll
take it off air.
- I'm interviewing you.
I mean, come on, what
are you doing here?
- I was curious.
- You wait till next
time I'm on your show,
then you can ask
me the questions.
Let's talk politics.
Do you want to talk
politics for a little bit?
- I guess, but I do
have to go to work.
I'm supposed to go at what time?
- Give me 10, give me 10, 10?
- 10 minutes?
- Five minutes.
- I'm supposed to be at work.
Five, you get five minutes
because I gotta change
and I gotta go to work.
- Okay, we'll even do
it quicker than that.
- All right.
- I'm trying to deal with
this Trump, DeSantis nonsense.
Everyone's angry,
everyone's fighting.
Obviously I love DeSantis, I
see what he's done in Florida.
I voted for Trump, I like
Trump, I like his kids.
But all hell's breaking loose,
everyone's trying
to kill each other.
Your take and how are you
dealing with it publicly
and all that stuff?
- We know what we're seeing,
and unfortunately there
may be no way out,
that there is very
little possibility
that Trump won't be the nominee,
and there's a strong
possibility that he will lose.
So we kind of know that, and
I've raised this question
to people that are
pro Trump people,
and like how can
you reconcile this?
And they go, well, the polls
aren't telling the whole story.
And I go, I don't know man.
It's like Democrats want
him to be the nominee.
That's the red flag
for me because,
and it's not Trump's
fault, it's the fact
that there is a faction of
people that hate him so strongly
that they will
put in the effort.
You know, if it's-
- They say it.
They say it every day.
- If it's 30% of the
population that despise him,
they're gonna feel like 90%.
And I know that to say
that you're not going
to counter that seems
like you're giving in.
But if you've got
other candidates that
could win, it's not.
And that's the thing.
And I think Trump is
amazing and hilarious,
but it's like, I
would say, dude,
I see you obviously
getting the nomination,
but I don't know how
you're gonna win.
Because it's being set
up so that you will lose.
So that's my take.
I think that's all
you're gonna get, Dave.
I think that's it.
- Do you have anything
else you want to say, Greg,
before you go to work,
whatever that is.
- I don't know what I'm doing.
I love you, Dave, that's
what I'm gonna say.
- Go homo.
- If you haven't bought my book,
it's still available somewhere.
You don't have to buy it, but
I would love it if you did.
And you should be on my
show very soon, I hope.
If not, this is over.
- I will come to that
craptastic city in September
when I'm back on the grid,
and we will do a show,
and then what do you say we go
out and get drunk after, huh?
- Yes, no sex with monkeys.
- Good-bye, Greg.
- See you later (laughs).
- If you're looking
for more enlightening
and maybe even
humorous conversations,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.